- So uh, today we're in
someone else's garden
instead of mine.
- Yeah and it didn't
look very familiar to me
- No yeah, it's pretty different,
We've got a pool.
- Lovely
it's freezing though, not good.
- What's the temperature of this pool?
- Four degrees,
so pretty much just above freezing.
Why?
- Bung this on.
there you go.
- nice uh, package.
- Cheers yeah it's pretty cold today
so it's you know
shriveled up a little bit.
Uh
- temperature?
- Lets have a little look
It is one, two, three, four
- Ball shiveringly cold
I've only fired one gun underwater
no I've never done it so
Okay so you're gonna fire
some sort of pistol underwater
for the very first time
- yeah
- This is a momentous occasion
- Day of firsts!
- Hey so what have we got here?
- We're using a different camera
usually we use the
Phantom Flex which shoots
2500 frames a second in full HD, 5720p.
That's just not fast enough for guns.
- so what's this then?
- This is the v1610
which does 18000 frames a second.
- eighteen thousand?
- Eighteen thousand!
- How many times slower
than real time is that?
- Lots
- it's about 750?
Yeah
- loads!
- Seven hundred and fifty times
slower than real time.
- So we're gonna get some
good underwater gun action
- Yeah we should be able to catch some
slower bullets as well.
- We might even go a
little bit slower as well
by lowering the resolution
to a standard F,
so we get 27000 frames a second.
- 27000?
- Yeah that'll be
alright, that'll be good.
- I'll do one last focus adjustment
and then we'll go.
- Ready on the other camera, yeah?
yep
- This might be on of the weirdest sights
I've ever seen Dan.
- you know you can actually just hold it,
you can be above the water.
- five, four, three, two, one!
- one!
- That sounded awesome underwater
- did it?
- That sounded cool!
- It was like a metallic sound,
it was like
- yeah?
- Sounded wicked!
- what have we got here?
- well this is the pistol
bullet, 9 millimeter.
- As you can see, the rifling
in the barrel of the pistol
has engaged in the outside soft um,
copper on the uh,
on the bullet itself.
And that is to impart spin on the bullet
to make it travel further,
and also cause better obscuration for-
- let me ask you a question
is this the first time
you've ever been smart
in a "Slo-Mo Guys" video?
- I think it is! Yeah.
yeah, that's a first!
- when it comes to guns
- So it's the first day I've
fired a weapon underwater,
and been smart.
- How about that!
- right what are we gonna fire next?
- Uh we're gonna get a revolver on the go.
Uh, see what that looks like.
- how do you think it will be different?
- Um, there'll be more gas coming out
between the revolver and the-
- here you go
- More gas coming out of here
- I like the color.
- yeah it's bling right?
- pretty pimp.
- yeah.
More gas coming out here
and there should be quite a lot coming out
because it's only a short barrel weapon
so it'll be quite interesting.
Yeah?
- Revolver of pimps
- alright we're gonna fire a
hollow point on this one.
You cool with that Dan?
- Happy with that.
- right just lower yourself in.
- three, two, one
- did it?
- that should've mushroomed out
Oh!
I hope people don't
take the audio from that
and replace it with something else
- That's definitely gonna happen
- thank you!
- Well done Dan.
- Cheers
- good wetsuit-ing.
- good days filming Dan?
- Yeah
- pretty cold?
- how long have you
been in the water total
do you think?
- hour probably?
- But it's been in and out in and out
so I've been like ah I'm nice and warm,
get back in.
it's not good!
- At least your pack- oh
- oh my package!
What? What you on about?
- Well I thought that
looked bloody awesome
- What did? That?
- No yeah that looked amazing
- I must say that it is freezing
and I've got really cold
watching you do this,
- Aw did you?
- so gotta pop a hat on.
- Aw diddums
- Well thanks to Destin
for letting us use his
awesome mirror rig,
he's actually gonna go shoot an AK47
on his channel right now.
- Yeah that'll be pretty cool man.
- So go and click that button right now
- Definitely check it out.
- It's cold!
- Aw man it was funny when you did it
it's not funny when I'm doing it
- Hello again just sneaking
this in at the end,
that video was shot about 8 months ago
and I did a pretty terrible
job in that last segment
of promoting Destins channel.
So I want to a better job right now.
uh, this video couldn't have
been done without Destin,
those were his pistols, we
flew to Alabama to shoot it
which is where he lives.
He built the giant periscope
mirror rig that we used, and
he also got hold of the amazing camera.
So, huge thanks to Destin
for making this one possible.
I imagine most of you have heard of Destin
but if you haven't, he
has a channel called
"Smarter Every Day"
which you should definitely subscribe to,
and on his video he's done the AK47
but he explains all the science behind it.
So basically everything
that's happening underwater
why you get those domes
that kind of bounce in
off each other like this.
All the science behind it is explained.
So if you're interested as to why
the bullet does what it does underwater,
and why the water reacts that way,
definitely go and watch his video
'cause it's extremely interesting.
Alright thanks.
- Got my uh nice warm dry shoes on
- cheers man
my bad
- just walking into the
pool with my loafers
- that's what you get for bringing loafers
anywhere around me!
- I like that that was
you knew what we were coming here for
and that was your shoe of choice
- It's because I only had one bag!
- He doesn't know Alabama at all
- I couldn't fit boots in there.
- Yep
- yep excellent yeah